Hey everybody thanks for tuning in to Dnews
today I'm Trace
I'm here at Lands End at the very edge of
San Francisco and it's a beautiful place
to come and see whales breaching or watch
seals but if you want to see wildlife up
close you have to go a hundred and
twenty miles south to the Monterey Bay
Aquarium so that's where we're headed
and we're going to show you some
incredible things. The California coast
is one of the most vibrant locations in
the world for marine research and
conservation efforts spanning 840 miles
this stretch of the coast facing the
Pacific Ocean has become home to
numerous ocean research institutions
such as the Monterey Bay Aquarium. The
researchers inside are constantly
looking forward utilizing technology and
new research techniques to study and
protect the ocean and the people that depend on it.
The aquarium is located along cannery
row in Monterey California named for the
numerous sardine canneries which
operated hear from the mid eighteen
hundreds until the 1970s.
A portal to the local wildlife and ecosystems its world acclaimed live exhibits
have a mission to inspire
ocean conservation.
You are standing next to the world's first ever live kelp forest
exhibit which moves constantly to allow
the kelp survive inside the aquarium we
got a rare view of how they do this.
Now you're standing above the kelp forest
exhibit just your left you'll notice a
pendulum-like of device that device is
actually forcing water up and down along
a chamber sending pulses into the
exhibits to simulate the ebb and flow of
the ocean. It's one thing to see it from
the surface but underwater you get a
real feel for the movement of the ocean.
Look around and you'll notice leopard
sharks, rockfish, giant kelp, and maybe even
spot a juvenile giant sea bass.
Across the aquarium is the open sea exhibit its 1.2 million gallons of water
is home to marine species that are more common
beyond our coastline in the featureless open ocean.
Each species in the open sea requires a specific diet and higher
temperature waters to replicate their natural environment.
This exhibit houses yellowfin tuna, bonito, scalloped hammerheads,
pelagic rays, and more than 30,000 sardines -- a nod to the Cannery's past.
If you look down, you'll see a massive green sea turtle weighing around 300 lbs!
Smaller fish such as these look downs
thrive in a much smaller exhibit
These fish swim
all day and night because they don't
sleep like land animals. Instead they lower
their metabolism to rest rather
than slipping into a dormant state like
you and me. Another reason they
never stop is they need to move to breathe
you may even catch a quick glimpse of
one of the lookdowns gills as they zip
past you. Their gills gather oxygen collected
from all the sea water flowing through
their mouths allowing them to breathe.
You are now surrounded by sea nettle jellyfish
normally if you were this close you'd feel a slight stingy sensation. The stingers are on the tentacles
trailing behind the jellyfish and
would feel painful if touched but not nearly as much
as say a bee sting. As the bell of the
jellyfish's pulses it could move slowly through the water
creating water currents that help it gather
passing food. As large plankton, jellies actually rely heavily
on ocean currents to move them for longer distances.
All of these exhibits are made possible by
marine researchers, animal caregivers,
expert divers and enthusiastic
volunteers who like millions of humans
before them have fallen in love with the sea.
Guys this place is incredible I've
never been able to go behind the scenes
and exhibits like that I hope you all
enjoyed it as much as I obviously did
but now let's head back up to San
Francisco
The Monterey Bay Aquarium, like other aquarium and marine research institutions around the world
are constantly tinkering with methods and technology
to study and protect marine wildlife.
In fact, the future of ocean conservation is propelled forward with technological innovations.
From autonomous ships, which will limit ocean pollution to the automation and sustainable practice of fish farming,
each step along the way will benefit from marine researchers considering the new possible.